hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today we are unboxing and trying out the
new DJI Ronin and I am so excited about
this I know a lot of you guys have been
very patiently waiting for it but guess
what it is here and we're gonna try it
out but first we have to do with the
unboxing so here it is we're wasting no
time today you're getting into this oh
wow
here it is let's do the official opening
everything is so perfectly organized so
the great thing is this has fast charge
so in two hours and 15 minutes that will
give you a full charge so since this
probably isn't charged we're gonna have
to do that after I unbox first things
first let's see what we have in here
looks like this is our little USB pouch
and cables two bolts screws little
accessories allen wrench there's a lot
of stuff in here next we've got our
mounting plate so this is where you
would actually put your camera
that's a velcro got a charging brick USB
is right there so we've got this handle
here which also doubles as a tripod so
this is great because of the our outlet
field you don't to completely rely on
handheld you can actually set it down
okay so here's the handle so this is
where you'll actually be attaching the
gimbal to the batteries also inside of
here and this can just screw right here
into the tripod here's our battery
levels which is only at one so we're
gonna definitely have to charge this
here is the gimbal itself let's get this
thing out of here
as gently as possible it's gotta come
out of your foot so you just attach the
gimbal right here to the handle there's
a little lock switch right here so you
can just flip that there to make sure
it's locked into place there you have it
so I think the trickiest part for me is
usually getting these things to balance
properly I'm hoping that it won't be too
difficult so let's see what we can do
let's get this thing to balance without
having a camera on it or
being turned on it's pretty good so the
ronan retails for $6.99 there'll be a
bunch more accessories available later
this year like a dual handle system
external focus motor and a gimble
mounting system it has four modes these
three are customizable and of course it
does have a sport mode it has superior
stabilization it can hold up to 8 pounds
and has an integrated camera control
there's automated features like panorama
time-lapse motion lapse track and rule
360 and with USB it has the ability to
power your camera and accessories so the
joystick this is really great because
this will give you one-handed control so
you don't have to worry about messing
around with other things you can just
basically control everything with one
hand while you're on the go so I can't
breathe I'm using this is the a7 3 and I
have this 18 millimeter on and this is
gonna be a nice wide-angle view it's
also fairly light because I didn't want
to have anything that was too heavy I
did set this up inside of the house just
to make sure everything was working but
I'll give you guys a quick little
rundown of how this all works so you
basically want everything to be
perfectly stable before you turn it on
so we have these two base plates there's
this little riser one that I put on
because this lens is a little bit wider
so now we're gonna slide this on there's
arrows to tell you which way is forward
thank you DJI so now we want to make
sure this is pretty stable and you can
adjust oh gosh ever so slightly but
don't worry because there is a catch
here so your camera will not fall off
that looks pretty good there's a little
lock over here so once you're happy with
how everything is looking lock it up
there's other adjustments that you can
make but I already have those preset up
so that this would be fairly simple that
looks pretty stable now let's turn it on
turn this one on first and then there's
also a power button on the gimbal that
you have to turn on
yes that's a sound that I like so it's
great about this is you can use it in
handheld mode there is a little trigger
here so you can basically control the
entire camera right here with one hand
there's a record button there's also
this little m button which will switch
into different user modes right now I'm
in three because that's the first one
that I set up which you think that I
would have set up number one first but I
did in one of those important things to
know is this the double tap of the
trigger that'll bring your camera back
to center so if you think things are not
going the way that they should just
double tap and it will bring it back
hold the trigger down and that will keep
the camera just how you have it super
smooth super steady and locked on and
here's what happens if you don't have it
locked yep it won't stay long the triple
tap is pretty much a vlogger favorite
it'll bring the camera all the way
around so now it's a selfie Ronin sure
most of you filmmakers and really
serious cinematographers you're gonna be
using that a lot for sure double tap
bring it back to the center talk about
the team
one of the things about some other
gimbals is there is an obstructed view
of the screen so with this there is an
unobstructed view it's a little bit
lower so you can actually see what
you're filming so that my friends is the
team am i using that properly so when
you first set it up you want to connect
it to the Rohner app mine's obviously
already connected but in here there's a
bunch of configurations here's where you
can customize user 1 2 & 3 you can also
go in here this is where you can do some
of the automated features capture
panoramas time-lapse motion lapse and
track so in all of these there's so many
different settings that you guys can get
into we're definitely not gonna be able
to get into all of these in today's
video there are so many things to do so
if you a four hour video if you went
through all of these things the t sit
the t drink the tea i don't know
that's the tea that's the teeth video
[Music]
[Applause]
I think so much for watching I hope you
guys enjoyed this quick little review of
the Ronin s I'm really excited to try
this out and shoot some really fun stuff
this thing can do so many things so I
probably will be covering some more of
that in another video but for now this
is it it's pretty awesome I'll put a
link in the description where you guys
can check it out and get more
information you guys have any questions
feel free to leave those in the comments
below and if you have anything else
you'd like to see me try with this also
leave those in the comments don't forget
to subscribe make sure you like the
video and of course hit the bell because
this is YouTube I got it I got to tell
you what to do cuz they change
everything every day anyway let's go
[Music]
Wow Wow this is so cool
me know the Ronin yeah that's like
you're excited about it I didn't know
skipping
like if I jump around it just makes them
more dramatic
Jim to cut before we're in here
[Music]
[Applause]